master of none there's a show where you
focus on the movie short circuit - and
this is an important it's important
topic for you
yes circuit - well the episodes called
Indians on TV it's about any people in
entertainment and short circuit - kind
of plays strange role in that for me
because I watched that movie when I was
like from the 87 yeah and it stars an
Indian guy and he's the main character
and I'd never seen a movie where an
Indian guy was like the main guy and
then as I got older I was like what
happened to that Indian actor I was in
short circuit - and then I googled
around and it's not an Indian guy it's
Fisher Stevens a Caucasian actor and
they put brown face makeup on him and it
was a crazy thing to discover and so we
talk about that a little in the episode
we we actually I always have standing by
a clip a montage of Fisher Stevens work
from the short circuit movies it's
always standing by we might as well take
a look at that here some female chicks
him it is only being buyers and several
mechanisms and others such machine-type
apparatus for the bit of sake give me
five hombre what are you gonna give me
the three oh well I don't know about you
but I am planning to scream and run good
answer
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't look at that living a long time
that's now you spoke with Fisher Stevens
it was you you did a New York Times
article and you spoke with Fisher seemed
you called him up is that right I did I
called him because you know you see that
stuff and it's like oh my god
like that's horrible it's racist and I
was writing this article New York Times
asked me to write it's ours like you
know what I want to call him and talk to
him and hear his side of the story
because I feel like now in like internet
culture it's just all about you know
we're all just sharks looking for blood
and anytime someone says racist stuff or
drops an N bomb I feel like there's all
these websites that are like yes we
could write about that for a week this
is awesome and and it's like we're not
sharks we shouldn't be looking for blood
we're human beings we should talk to
people and look for dialogue and
understanding and and I talked to him it
was really interesting because you know
he was like a young actor he was like 21
years old they offered him this huge
part in a movie originally it's supposed
to be a white guy and then some person
at some point was like you know what we
changed to an Indian guy can you do
Indian which is an insane question and
he was like yeah I figured it out and
any work with a dialect coach and you've
spent time in India and he tried to do
it in a thoughtful way so it was
interesting to talk to him yeah and hear
that side of it it's nice that you
reached out to him and and sort of yeah
I'm human eyes the side of the story now
this is interesting I'm it's fascinating
that you brought up Fisher Stevens
because one of his co-stars from
short-circuit came by the show today and
is hanging out backstage and heard that
you were on one to come out and say hi
and I think we should bring them out
here a few short circuit fans please
welcome Johnny Five let's get him out
here
[Applause]
hey 25 thank you very much for joining
us no problem counting all right Oh
five-year you're looking like you've
aged a little bit you look a little
older than you did back it up well you
look great Fisher Stevens
I'm not Fisher Stevens you look just
like him no Richard Stevens was an
Indian he was a white guy in brown face
so are you a white guy in brown face I'm
Indian I'm an Indian person how come you
don't sound Indian johnny-five
that's nuts really ignorant you know
I'll be like me saying oh you're a robot
how come you don't go people
whoa whoa hey that is offensive oh now I
see your point
thank you Hey want to grab a drink after
the show I'm buying all right sure cool
I'll meet you at Jumbo's clown room
[Laughter]
that's a great joke if you know what
Jumbo's clown
[Applause]
thanks a lot
Johnny five
[Applause]